The killer doll has some killer pipes, but a
creepy song wasn't always part of the horror
hit "M3GAN". Here's how the unsettling
lullaby made it into the final cut.
"M3GAN" has been sashaying her way into the pop
culture zeitgeist more and more as we head into
the opening stretch of 2023. From the killer
doll flick's impressive critical reception to
the sizable box office haul of its opening
weekend, it looks like there's a new horror
icon in town — who could probably beat the
stuffing out of competitors like Chucky.
"You should probably run."
All the same, "M3GAN" has a surprising amount
of heart for a movie with such a campy tone
and goofy premise. While the android definitely
seems to be looking out for number one by the end
of the movie, she also appears to genuinely care
about Cady and have her best interests at heart.
This friendlier side of her is shown when she
serenades the troubled Cady to sleep with an
on-the-nose song choice in the film that had fans
absolutely buzzing on social media. Of course,
fans might recall that Anna Kendrick sang the very
same song in the musical comedy "Pitch Perfect,"
and in the same acapella style that M3GAN does.
However, Jenna Davis, who voices the android,
performs a double-sided take on "Titanium" by
David Guetta and Sia. No matter how nicely it's
sung, this lullaby is a little less than
comforting, and more of a major threat.
Many fans loved the needle drop,
with one predicting on Twitter,
Meanwhile, others were just happy to
have another reason to fall in love
with the movie. Another fan posted,
With "M3GAN" singing and dancing
her way into everyone's good graces,
it probably won't be long before the android
returns to terrorize another family in the
inevitable sequel. Until then, fans can listen
to her rendition of "Titanium" on Spotify.
M3GAN is a dancing and singing sensation, but she
wasn't always meant to be that way. One piece of
movie trivia that's been making the rounds
is that the iconic dance M3GAN does toward
the film's finale wasn't in the original script.
Director Gerard Johnstone told TooFab that he came
up with the dance on the fly, and he was just
hoping people would embrace it. Johnstone said,
However, now we know that M3GAN singing
"Titanium" was also from the mind of Johnstone.
He did an interview with Variety where he spoke
about all things related to "M3GAN." He revealed
that the musical number wasn't in the original
script, but he was allotted enough creative
freedom to the point he could have fun with the
moment when M3GAN comforts Cady. He explained,
Whatever the source of inspiration was,
it led to an instantly memorable moment that
helped make M3GAN a great movie villain.